En tout cas, c'est le constat que c'est 1 échec,
ça c'est sûr. Mais ce que vous dites sur les
institutions européennes, c'est quand-même délirant.
On a des institutions qui sont complètement hors-sol,
qui sont déconnectées des réalités,
qui ne voient pas
la colère et la mobilisation sans
précédent du monde paysan
pour voter en pleine mobilisation,
euh, des agriculteurs, 1 loi 1,
1, 1 traité de libre-échange avec le Kenya,
avec le Chili,
pour apporter des bonnes.
Ok, on dit, mais, mais qui qui aux manettes ?
Et quand on regarde les députés qui ont voté,
parce que il y a des députés européens qui ont voté,
bah, les députés
membres de la majorité présidentielle, ici en France,
membres du groupe qu'on appelle rognault,
ont tous voté ce traité de libre-échange.
Donc moi, je veux bien que le
gouvernement soit au chevet des agriculteurs ce soir,
mais euh, c'est euh. 2 poids de mesure,
c'est 1 écran de fumée. Ce soir,
la réalité
c'est que quand ils sont par le monde européen,
ils votent l'ensemble des traités de libre-échange
qui viennent mettre
instaurer 1 concurrence déloyal
avec nos
agriculteurs et les agriculteurs du monde entier,
ça c'est insupportable.